our next guests are a father-daughter
acting duo from the highly anticipated
new film flag day two-time academy award
winner sean pan directs the drama and
stars as john vogel a notorious con man
and's daughter dylan portrays vogel's
daughter jennifer flag day is based on
the true story of her father and
daughter's complicated relationship over
the years critics are calling this dylan
penn's breakout performance in her
biggest role yet
did you tell anyone
did anybody pick you up
the truth is i've
actually been out for a while
how long
i'm here in a bit
are you hearing a bit what the hell
don't call or write and you've been out
of here in a bit i wrote you 100 times
from prison i didn't hear anything back
no response nothing
why would i think anything would change
when i got out here
and sean and dylan pan are with us now
good morning to you both thanks for
being with us thanks for having us sean
how did this start because you actually
you had you you first saw a script for
this over a decade ago yeah did you have
dylan in mind even then well i started
to read the script and within 30 pages
uh her face became
imprinted on it and it was not something
i could see any other way from that time
really yeah
dylan how'd it go when he approached you
for the first time about the role
the first time i was a resounding no
um i really why no yeah i was wondering
that took a while acting is just not
something i ever thought i would do in a
million years
especially at that time i just always
wanted to be
i wanted to be in the industry but
behind the camera whether it was
producing directing writing
um and i also felt like i just didn't
have any life experience i'd read the
book and i loved the book but i didn't
have experience to bring you know to
reference
um to bring to that character and then
you know 15 years later i'm 30 now um
kind of different and didn't your mom
your mom who's also an actress because i
i often wonder if maybe it's in your dna
did your mom say you should think about
it too
no i mean
this was a special i don't think either
of them
suggested that i act
but i mean this role working with him oh
yes i think either it's terrifying that
you're working with him because he's
sean penn and he's your dad or there's
something comforting about it did your
mom say you might want to yeah she said
she said when i was thinking of opting
out of it um this time around she said
it was she had the best experience
working with him as a
so i felt like
so you signed up because he's a good
director
well obviously
also working with your family you don't
know if it's going to be in a
professional environment it could be
disastrous or great yeah but this is the
first time so
sean you've said it you've got a daily
dose of pride working with her and when
i was watching the movie number one
there's some very intense scenes between
the two of you which are knockout on
both sides when i was watching the two
of you work together i thought are they
sending signals to each other is there
something that they do that no one else
can do what was it like for you
directing her
well you know as it turned out there's a
there's a an expression that
that i'll borrow
there i think that there is a blood
harmony
and that in that we were able to have an
intuitive shorthand so much of the time
um i typically don't want to
put an idea in an actor's head until
i've seen what they are bringing
uh without that
and
very
it was
very rare that that i really gave a lot
of direction to her she was just a truth
machine and a truth
did you ever say to him dad i don't
really like that direction or why don't
we do it this way
yeah we did
not often yeah how did he respond
he was he's a great collab collaborator
so i was that was really surprising
actually what do you mean i just thought
he would
kind of
shoot me down i also think we were on
the same page a lot of times that helped
did you see something in him you maybe
hadn't seen before
um
no i think just how fair he is on set is
was a no
surprise also he just treated me like an
actor not
not his daughter which was really
helpful sean you mentioned when you were
reading the script after about 30 pages
all you could see was your daughter's
face in the character of the daughter
did you also see your face in the main
character and the character of the
criminal not at all it was it is this is
despite my
despite me i ended up having the the
great opportunity to act with her
because i would never i've never thought
to direct myself i want to when i direct
a movie i want to just direct a movie
we had another actor involved for a very
long time leading up to it and we were
in pre-production on location just a
couple of weeks away from starting and
that actor had a a personal a family
issue and had to bow out
and
i i couldn't find anybody else and you
had an academy award winner just sitting
around yourself and you were like why
don't we put him in the game yeah it was
from directing which is a 17 and a half
hour a day job to begin with to consider
but then once i got in there and had
that
you know i wouldn't trade it for
anything you never shy away from
controversy sean and i love that you're
saying to people when you come see this
movie please be vaccinated i think it's
a message we need to send we're all
vaccinated here at the table yes yes we
want we want you know as with any movie
we want to have as many people see it
and see it in the theater
as possible but i do ask
sincerely that anyone who has chosen not
to be vaccinated who is interested in
the movie wait for it to stream since
we've got you here we have to talk about
haiti because since the 2010 earthquake
you've been back and forth there many
times
and you've got your non-profit core that
works there what are you what is your
team doing now so from day one we had
our heavy equipment teams go in
helping in the search and rescue and
clearing roadways for access for
resources
and medical teams i'll be going down on
tuesday and i'll have be able to give a
better um a personal assessment but i'm
in contact with the teams and uh they're
very active and it's it's it's one foot
in front of the other
how tough is the situation from what you
heard it's extremely difficult in part
one one complication beyond that we had
in 2010 is that the road
between port-au-prince and the affected
area in the southwest
is a gang-dominated road and so
even ambulances will be hijacked and and
so on so everything has to come in
by rotary or by fixed wing or by sea
uh but they you know there's great need
for medical supplies there's great need
for support there because it is so
complicated well you always step up sean
penn i've heard you say that you know
helping is in the family dna i've seen
you too dylan on the road i want to end
with you because you're the only one
that table that would know this what's
the best thing about sean penn as a
father what's the best thing about sean
penn as an actor
it might be one in the same
i think just his adventurous soul and
his like willingness to take risks
that's really as a father like just
i have a lot of memories of just
i don't want to share the personal
memories but like about adventures and
yeah as a director
similar very cool
flag day is out in theaters now